- [Narrator] We have
two different statements
written in English
that I would like you to pause this video
and try to write as an
algebraic expression.
All right, now let's
work on this first one.
So you might be tempted to
say, all right, I have five.
So let me just write a five,
times and I'll write a dot
because when we're dealing with algebra,
if you write a traditional
multiplication sign,
it can get confused with an X.
So five times
the difference of X and two.
The difference of X and two,
we could write as X minus two,
but this expression has a problem
because whoever's interpreting it,
if they're following order of operations,
which they should,
that would mean that they would multiply
the five and the X first
and then subtract two.
But that's not what's
going on in the sentence.
It's five times,
not X, but the difference of X and two.
So what you need to do is
put parentheses here
to make sure that you take the difference
of X and two first,
and then multiply that by five.
Now, with that in mind,
let's tackle this example right over here,
10 times the sum of Y and three.
Well, once again,
if you just wrote 10 times
the sum
of Y and three,
you'll run into the same problem.
someone would interpret this as,
hey, maybe I should
multiply 10 and Y first,
because that's what order of
operations would tell me to do,
but that's not what we want.
We want 10 times, not just Y,
but the sum of Y and three.
So that's where the parentheses
are really important to make sure
that we take the sum of Y and three first
and then multiply that by 10.